around 2004 bidding began for the
opportunity to host the 2010 World Cup
which is ultimately awarded to South
Africa the first time the tournament
would be held on the African continent
but even for this historic event FIFA
executives and others corrupted the
process by using bribes to influence the
hosting decision the indictment also
alleges that corruption and bribery
extended to the 2011 presidential FIFA
election and two agreements regarding
sponsorship of the Brazilian national
soccer team by a major US sportswear
company in short these individuals
through these organizations engaged in
bribery to decide who would televise
games where the games would be held and
who would run the organization
overseeing organized soccer worldwide
one of the most popular sports around
the globe and while at least one FIFA
executives served as CONCACAF president
without pay
there was little altruism involved as he
alone is alleged to have taken more than
10 million dollars in bribes over a 19
year period and amassed a personal
fortune from his ill-gotten gains